>> IF WE ACT THE WRONG WAY, WE
JUMP TOO SOON, THEN YOU COULD
SEE A RESURGENCE OF THIS
DISEASE.
THAT’S SOMETHING WE SHOULD AIL
BE REALLY MINDFUL OF.
WE GOT ONE CHANCE TO GET IT
RIGHT.
IN THIS CASE I WILL CALL MYSELF
A CONSERVATIVE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE SMART
ABOUT DOING IT IN STAGES, MAKING
SURE WE CAN CONFIRM THAT WE’RE
CONTAINING THE DISEASE MORE AND
MORE, GETTING IT BACK TO WHERE
IT WAS, YOU KNOW, A MONTH OR TWO
AGO.
BEFORE YOU REALLY START TO OPEN
UP A LOT.
AND, LOOK, I WANT TO SEE PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK AS MUCH AS ANYONE.
I FEEL IT URGENTLY.
BUT WE HAVE GOT TO SECURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY FIRST OF ALL
NEW YORKERS AND OBVIOUSLY ALL
AMERICANS.
BRIAN: AND YOU HAVE GOT TO
WONDER WHAT STATES OPEN UP FIRST
AND WOULD NEW YORK BE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THAT LIST?
LET’S ASK KELLYANNE CONWAY,
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT.
THE BIG FOCUS THIS WEEK IN THE
ROSE GARDEN IS GETTING THE
ECONOMY GOING AGAIN.
HOW REALITY BASED IS MAY 1st?
KELLYANNE CONWAY?
>> FOR SOME PLACES IT CERTAINLY
CAN BE A REALITY.
IF THERE IS TESTING AVAILABLE,
IF YOU YOUR INFECTION RATES ARE
LOW, DEATH RATES ARE LOW.
HOSPITAL CAPACITY IS THERE,
INCLUDING VENTILATORS AND
MEDICAL PERSONNEL BEDS, BEDS IN
THE ICU.
ALL OF THAT IS TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR
FROM THE BEGINNING IS HE NOT
LOOKING AT A DATE.
IS HE LOOKING AT DATA.
HE WILL LISTEN TO THE HEALTH AND
MEDICAL EXPERTS AS WELL.
THESE ARE PARALLEL TRACKS.
THEY SOON WILL JOIN.
NOW, THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY,
I AGREE COMPLETELY THAT HE WOULD
BE INCREDIBLY CAUTIOUS TO LOOK
AT A MAY 1st DATE OR ANY TIME
SOON.
NEW YORK CITY HAS BEEN AMONG THE
HARDEST HIT, HALF OF THE DEATHS
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY SADLY HAVE
OCCURRED IN THAT STATE.
WE HAVE 24% OF OUR NATION’S
COUNTIES THAT HAVE HAD NO
INFECTIONS.
WE HAVE GOT ABOUT 29 STATES THAT
WOULD MEET.
SO CRITERIA THAT I HAVE PUT OUT
FIRST.
I THINK THE FUNDAMENTAL POINT
HERE IS THAT THE BEST PERSON TO
REVIVE THE DONALD TRUMP ECONOMY
IS DONALD TRUMP.
AND WITH HIM IN THE LEAD WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNORS, WORKING ON
THAT HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
GUIDANCE, AND NOW WORKING WITH
SO MANY LEADERS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WHO WILL COME FORTH AND
SHARE THEIR BEST PRACTICES,
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY MAY WANT
TO DO IN THEIR PLACES OF WORK.
AND I WOULD SAY TO EVERYONE,
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WAS PUT OUT
A WEEK AGO.
THE CDC AND THE WHITE HOUSE PUT
OUT UPDATED GUIDANCE FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WORKERS.
THAT COVERED ABOUT 16 DIFFERENT
TYPES OF WORK.
EVERYTHING FROM OUR FOOD SUPPLY
TO ENERGY, WASTE MANAGEMENT,
SANITATION, AND A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT GUIDANCE ALSO GIVES US A
GOOD LOOK AHEAD.
BECAUSE, WE’RE TALKING ABOUT
ASYMPTOMATIC AND EXPOSE, NEVER
EXPOSED, TEMPERATURE CHECKS
SHOULD HAPPEN.
HERE’S HOW THE FACILITIES AND
THE PLACES OF WORK SHOULD
CONTINUE TO SANITIZE THEIR
WORKPLACE.
EVERYBODY SHOULD CONTINUE THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
WEARING A MASK OR FACE CLOTH,
ACCORDING TO THE CDC’S GUIDANCE
OF TWO WEEKS AGO NOW.
SO THERE ARE PROTOCOLS IN PLACE
THAT WILL CONTINUE THIS NEW
NORMAL THAT WE HAVE ALL BECOME
ACCUSTOMED TO AND AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN PRACTICING ROUTINELY SO
WELL TO THEIR CREDIT.
WE WILL CONTINUE IN OUR PLACES
OF WORK.
IT WON’T HAPPEN IN NEW YORK, I
WOULD DOUBT IT, BY A CERTAIN
DATE ANY TIME SOON.
OPENING UP PLACES OF WORSHIP,
PLACES OF WORK, SOME EVER OUR
SCHOOLS AND PLACES WHERE
CHILDREN ARE CARED FOR SEEMS TO
BE ONE OF THE KEYS UNLOCKING THE
ECONOMY.
THIS WILL BE THE GREAT AMERICAN
COME BACK.
WE HAVE 17 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
HAVE FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
1/3 OF RENTERS DID NOT PAY THEIR
RENT LAST MONTH.
THIS IS TRAGIC FOR THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT’S THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WE WANT INDIVIDUALS AND
INDUSTRIES TO COME ROARING BACK
IN THIS TRUMP ECONOMY.
AINSLEY: KELLYANNE CONWAY, YOU
MENTIONED THE GUIDELINES AND
GETTING BACK TO WORK A LOT.
HOW WILL WE DO THIS?
WHO WILL HELP WITH THIS?
WILL IT BE GUIDELINES THAT
DR. FAUCI AND DR. BIRX COME UP
WITH OR SOMEONE ELSE?
>> BOTH OF THE ABOVE.
THEY ARE WORKING HARD ON THAT.
SO IS THE WHOLE TEAM.
IN THE SITUATION ROOM MOST DAYS
HAVE YOU GOT THE VICE PRESIDENT,
DR. BIRX, DR. FAUCI, I SIT RIGHT
BEHIND THEM IN THE SECOND ROW AS
DO A NUMBER OF WHITE HOUSE
STAFFERS, WE HEAR THEM EVERY
DAY.
THEY ARE WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
ON THE HEALTH OUTCOMES TALKING
ABOUT THE NEW HEALTH OUTCOMES,
FOR EXAMPLE, STATE BY STATE,
COUNTY BY COUNTY, REGION BY
REGION.
BUT NOW THEY’RE ALSO TALKING IN
TANDEM ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
TO OPEN UP PIECES OF THE
ECONOMY.
SO DR. BIRX, OBVIOUSLY THE
CORONAVIRUS COORDINATOR HERE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR THE TASK
FORCE AND THE HEAD OF THE CDC
DR. RED FIELD ALONG WITH FEMA,
CDC AND FEMA WILL HAVE MAJOR BIG
PENS, IF YOU WILL, IN PERMS OF
THE GUIDANCE AND WHAT HAS TO
HAPPEN.
AND THAT WILL BE ISSUED SOON IT.
IS EXACTLY THAT.
IT’S GUIDANCE.
AS THE PRESIDENT MADE CLEAR IN
THE ROSE GARDEN THE GOVERNORS
WILL COME FORWARD WITH OWN
PLANS, SOME ARE BANDING TOGETHER
FOR REGIONAL DISCUSSIONS BASED
ON THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR
INTERCONNECTED, I GUESS, MARKET
SYSTEM.
BUT, AGAIN, IT TOOK A
BUSINESSMAN TO BECOME PRESIDENT
TO JUICE THIS ECONOMY IN A
FAIRLY HISTORIC WAY FOR MODERN
TIMES.
COMPLETING THESE TRADE DEALS,
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATINGS WERE
LOW.
THE TAXES WERE LOWER.
ALL OF THAT THE ENERGY
DOMINANCE.
THE DEREGULATION.
ALL OF THIS CREATED A BOOMING
ECONOMY FOR SOME AMERICANS AND
THIS PRESIDENT HELPED CREATE
THAT ECONOMY.
THIS PRESIDENT WILL BE IN THE
LEAD TO RESURGE THAT ECONOMY.
STEVE: RIGHT.
KELLYANNE CONWAY LAST NIGHT THE
PRESIDENT DID ANNOUNCE HE WAS
GOING TO SUSPEND PAYMENTS TO THE
W.H.O. AS HE TRIES TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT EXACTLY WAS GOING ON THERE.
TRYING TOCHINA WAS CLEARLY DECEP
THE EARLY STAGES OF THE PANDEMIC
AND THE W.H.O. REPEATED A LOT OF
THAT TO THE WORLD AS IF IT WAS
EXACTLY ACCURATE.
THERE WAS A STORY -- I’M LOOKING
AT FOXNEWS.COM.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS LEAKED
CABLES THAT RENEWED THEORIES ON
THE ORIGIN OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
APPARENTLY TWO YEARS AGO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON IN A
PARTICULAR LAB IN WUHAN.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> SURE.
WELL, THAT’S ALL OUT IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN, EVERYTHING THAT
YOU HAVE JUST SAID.
FIRST, LET ME TAKE IT -- THE
W.H.O. FUNDING.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO
RECOGNIZES THAT OUR COUNTRY,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, YOU THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE PAID 830-SOME
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS TO THE W.H.O.
CHINA PAID 10% OF THAT.
CHINA, FRANCE, ITALY AND INDIA
COMBINED PAID ABOUT ONE TENTH
WHAT THE UNITED STATES HAS PAID
INTO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
IT’S MEANT TO COORDINATE
RESPONSES AND KEEP AN EYE ON
THINGS.
PARTICULARLY IN THE CASE OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD.
SO WE PAY INTO THAT, AND IS IT
SO MUCH TO ASK THE MINOR
DIVIDEND, THE MINOR RETURN ON
OUR INVESTMENT IS FOR THE W.H.O.
TO BE HONEST ABOUT THE ORIGINS
OF THE VIRUS IN WUHAN, ABOUT THE
FACT THAT IT WAS HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
TRANSMISSION?
THEY LIED ABOUT THAT OR WEREN’T
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THAT.
SO THIS IS ABOUT TRANSPARISH IS
I AND ACCOUNTABILITY, BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN SO HARD HIT IN THIS
COUNTRY AND WE WERE LISTENING TO
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AROUND
THE WORLD.
I SAT IN SOME OF THOSE EARLY
MEETINGS.
WE WERE GETTING AMERICANS AND
REPATRIATING THEM FROM WUHAN AND
OTHER PARTS IN CHINA.
THE PRESIDENT TOOK DECISIVE AND
IMMEDIATE ACTION THE END OF
JANUARY TO SHUT DOWN FLIGHTS IN
CHINA THAT WAS CRITICIZED BY THE
W.H.O.
IT WAS CRITICIZED BY OTHER
PEOPLE AS GENERAL KNOW PHOBIC
AND RACIST AND TRAVEL BANS DON’T
WORK.
THIS ONE SURE DID.
WE HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO KNOW.
AND EVERY RIGHT TO KNOW BECAUSE
BECAUSE WHAT HAS WHAT HAPPENED
IN PANDEMIC.
ANOTHER REASON, SOME OF THE
SCIENTISTS AND DOCTORS SAY THERE
COULD BE OTHER STRAINS LATER ON
THIS.
COULD COME BACK IN THE FALL IN A
LIMITED WAY.
THIS IS COVID-19, NOT COVID 1,
FOLKS.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION FACTS AND FIGURES
WOULD BE ON TOP OF THAT THIS IS
JUST A PAUSE RIGHT NOW.
SO THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION,
EXAMINATION TO WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW THE
FACTS.
WE PAID OVER 830 MILLION IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS CHINA PAID ONE
TENTH OF THAT.
BRIAN: CHINA FUNDAMENTALLY LIED
AND WE STILL DON’T HAVE THE
TRUTH AND THE W.H.O. DIDN’T STOP
IT.
BUT CHINA IS THE PROBLEM.
MEANWHILE, THE PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO GET THIS ECONOMY
REBOOTED AGAIN.
AND HE IS CALLING ON SOME
EXPERTS FROM ALL DIFFERENTIAL
ASPECTS OF OUR ECONOMY ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HEAR MARK COULD
YOU BEGIN CONSTANT GUEST ON OUR
SHOW AND NETWORK WANTS TO HELP
OUT 100 BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
THE SPORTS THING GOING WITH THE
NBA.
WHAT COULD YOU TELL US ABOUT
THIS?
>> THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND MANY PEOPLE
INVOLVED WHO ARE ON THE LIST WHO
WILL PARTICIPATE IN CALLS AND
GIVE ADVICE AS WELL.
THE LIST IS ILLUSTRATIVE.
I DOUBT IT’S EXHAUSTIVE.
THERE ARE SO MANY TALENTED MEN
AND WOMEN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
WHO WANT TO BRING TO BEAR THEIR
SUCCESSES, THEIR BEST PRACTICES
AND THEIR PLACES OF WORK AND
FIGURE OUT WHO THEY, TOO, CAN BE
PART OF THE GREAT AMERICAN
COMEBACK.
THE PRESIDENT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
HAD A FABULOUS CALL WITH THE
HEADS OF ALL THE SPORTS LEAGUES.
WE KNOW EMOTIONALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY RESTARTING SOME OF
OUR LIVE SPORTS ACTION WOULD
GOAL ALONG WAY COMING BACK.
CAPTAINS OF INDUSTRY, REALLY
RUNS THE GAMUT OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO COMBINE WITH PUBLIC
SECTOR EFFORTS THAT CONGRESS IS
PASSING TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
RELIEF.
THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING 24/7.
BRIAN: GOTCHA.
>> PUBLIC SECTOR.
LEVEL GO BACK TO ONE THING YOU
SAID ABOUT CHINA THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
DR. REDFIELD.
BRIAN: WE JUST HAVE TO RUNCHTS
I’M SORRY.
ON FEBRUARY 28TH, WE HAD 14
CASES IN THIS COUNTRY.
14.
WE HAD HAD TWO HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
TRANSMISSIONS AND THEY WERE
SPOUSES.
ONE IN CALIFORNIA, ONE IN
ILLINOIS.
THIS JUST CATAPULTED AND YOU
KNOW THAT W.H.O. DID NOT CALL
THIS A GLOBAL PANDEMIC UNTIL
MARCH?
I HAD REFERRED TO IT AS A
PANDEMIC ON YOUR SHOW AS A
LAYPERSON BEFORE THEY HAD
REFERRED TO IT.
SO THE FOOT-DRAGGING IS ALSO A
CONCERN.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO TAP INTO
PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
PUBLIC SECTOR AND GET THIS
ECONOMY ROARING FOR MANY
AMERICANS.